hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt endlich schaffe ich es mal ein baby
update zuzureden es schon fünf monate
alt und die zeit verging wie im flug und
eigentlich wollte ich immer jeden monat
ein update machen aber ich habe
irgendwie das geschafft wie gesagt es
geht einfach so schnell vorbei
vielleicht kurz so aktuell ist wie
gesagt sie ist fünf monate alt am 24 ab
märz geworden und aktuell wiegt sie
glaube ich 6,8 kilogramm und ist über 62
cm auch schon aber ich finde es sieht
ganz selig aus also ich gucke mal
darüber weil das sitzt nämlich gerade
bock hat auf dem schoß und knabbert
gerade anzahl empfänger ja also was
vielleicht sagen kann also mit airlines
im moment echt total angenehm
der anfang ist natürlich wie immer ganz
schwer also die ersten zwei drei wochen
finde ich jemand dann ganz schwierig war
weil man halt so als mama wieder in
diesen schlaf wach rhythmus kommt und
macht nicht mehr durchschlafen kann und
einfach sich daran gewöhnen muss dass
man eben wieder aufsteht macht aber das
hat ganz gut hinbekommen ich habe auch
die erste zeit nicht so viel besuch
bekommen also wir haben es da ganz gut
so ein bisschen abgeblockt und gesagt
okay jetzt nur die engste familie weil
man einfach sich an das leben zu vierter
natürlich auch gewinnen muss und die
kleidung muss ich erstmal zu hause ein
leben ja morath dürfen amazon dem finger
schon unglaublich ja also ich finde ganz
interessant zu sehen wie man wirklich
jeden tag und jede woche bei den kindern
was neues entdeckt und im moment ist
gerade weise bekommt denke ich mal so
die ersten zähnchen soweit die haben
sich schon ziemlich früh angekündigt und
ich habe auch da war sie drei monate alt
habe ich auch ein zahn hier unten in der
ecke entdeckt also direkt an da kam so
ein bisschen raus haben also die weiße
spitze gesehen und dann wieder
verschwunden und aber es hat kein fieber
bekommen und sonst auch keine probleme
sie rabatt halt immer so ein bisschen
ist alles anders ja ich habe ein paar
fragen gesammelt und zwar haben viele
gefragt ob samira eifersüchtig ist also
samira ist wirklich gar nicht
eifersüchtig
sie hat sich ja auch das geschwisterchen
gewünscht und sie macht das wirklich
sehr gut als
spielt ganz toll mit ihr und sagte mir
abnahmen abnahm das heißt so etwas wie
eine große schwester
aber sie sagt das halt immer im
typischen sagt man das irgendwie immer
so knapp nahm an dem und so und dann
spielt sie immer ganz toll mit ihr und
gestern war es zum beispiel so da habe
ich die l hingelegt aber sogleich
geschlafen und hat der morath ds amira
gefragt was ich gefragt ob sie sie zum
schlafen bringt genau obst zuschlag und
sie zum schlafen sagt ich weiss nicht
verbrauche ich sie zum schlafen bringen
kann aber ich kann sie zum lachen
bringen
falls sie jetzt ich sage auch gerade
müde und möchte lieber ins bett im
hintergrund also bei den videos immer so
ich habe hier vorne beim sofa habe ich
so einen lauf geht hat da lege ich sie
dann rein oder sie darf uns zu gucken da
haben auch so eine wippe da liegt ja
auch ganz gerne drin so lasse ich sie da
nicht ganz lange drin liegen also
entweder liegt sie eben laufgitter oder
schlägst du dann halt auch auf dem boden
auf so eine krabbeldecke und da kann sie
da auch hin und her cool an wie sie
möchte
mittlerweile kann sie sich auch schon
drehen vom bauch auf den rücken
vom rücken offenbach geht es nur nicht
weil das ist ja auch ziemlich schwierig
man braucht ja ganz viele bauchmuskeln
dazu und das schafft sie noch nicht ganz
aber sie kann sich schon früh findet man
auch die seite drehen
das heißt sie schon so weit dass man sie
wirklich nicht mehr alleine irgendwo
liegen lassen kann sondern immer
irgendwie entweder im laufgitter oder
auf den boden legen muss baby knast ja
wann schön abwicklers ja sie greift dann
auch jetzt immer schon ganz viel und
auch schon ganz gezielt und ich fand so
die übergangsphase ganz toll ich meine
ganz am anfang die ersten wochen kann
man ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so viel
mit baby anfang
ich habe ich dann auch recht gefragt was
habe ich eigentlich mit samira gemacht
als sie klein war aber am anfang muss
man halt kuscheln und schmusen und dann
fängt sie irgendwann an dich zu erkennen
also merkt dann auch sie schaut denen
die augen und fixiert und erkennt dann
auch die gesichter vor allem erkennt sie
schon geräusche und schaut dann auch
immer hin und her und jetzt greift sie
eben ganz viel und fängt doch an zu
lachen
man darf natürlich auch das andere kind
vergessen ist auch genau was da fand ich
diese große kind vergessen die seminar
zb habe jetzt gelernt fahrrad zu fahren
radfahrer fahren
juni ohne stützräder ja ohne stützräder
also mit stützrädern konzert schon immer
aber ohne stützräder und der murat geht
dann immer schön mit dir raus oder auch
wenn wir im kinderwagen unterwegs sind
darf dann von mehreren dem herr fahrrad
fahren also man darf auf keinen fall das
große kind vernachlässigen
ich beziehe sie dann aber mit ein als
sie darf mit mir dann auch die ela
wickeln und hilft dann immer ganz
fleißig und bringt mir die tücher und
alles mögliche und es macht sie halt
echt gut
vor allem darf sich natürlich auch auf
den schoß nehmen das finde ich auch
immer ganz wichtig sich dann alles
machen was wir auch machen
und ja wenn ich zum beispiel stille dann
stellt sie ihr baby oder ihren hund oder
irgendwie war dann sitzt auch so da an
der wurst und hat dann den täter und ihr
baby da jetzt habe ich gerade kleine
schlafen gelegt also bei es ist immer
noch so die will immer so alle drei
dreieinhalb stunden hat sie hunger und
möchte das essen auch nachts leider noch
wo weihnachts geht's eigentlich also
wenn ich sie zum beispiel abends um acht
ins bett weg er hat so eine schlafphase
die geht dann etwas länger also meistens
so bisschen eins der liste dann so die
mahlzeit um 11 zum beispiel aus und da
muss ich nachts eigentlich noch zwei mal
aufstehen ist zeigen ich gar nicht so
schlimm und tagsüber ist es eben noch
alle 34 3 bis 4 stunden und sie schläft
hat nicht mehr so viel wie ganz am
anfang also sie es dann ziemlich lange
wach und spielt jetzt auch ganz viel
und irgendwann wird sie aber müde das
kündigt sich auch immer ganz gut an
da reibt sich dann immer die augen und
wenn man dann den moment erwischt und
die ella ins bett legt dann hat das ganz
gut und schläft sie innerhalb von ein
paar minuten
ansonsten muss man so ein bisschen
dastehen und für die stirn streicheln
das max ist sehr gerne
oder was ja auch gern mag als er sie
schläft meist auf dem bauch und da muss
man ein bisschen auf den popo immer
klopfen und dann schläft hand einige
probleme sorgen sie total ist alles
kaputt sagte professor falls sie wieder
immer so ein bisschen pop klopfer und
dann geht s dann schläft ein
ja und wie steht nachts auf davon kann
ich gar nichts mit jagd weil du halt
immer weiter schläft ach so na ja ich
stehe nachts auf und stehe morgens ist
er was ich aber nicht mehr mache ist
nachts zu wickeln das heißt ich wickle
sehr abend soll das letzte mal zieht sie
dann oben dann bekommt sie in pyjama an
dann ist sowieso ein
auch und rhythmus und so eine art und
routine und dann lege ich sie ins bett
steht sie nachts noch eins bis zwei mal
und wickelt dann aber nicht weil ich
einfach sehe ich auf dem schlaf reisen
möchte also es läuft ruhig hat die nacht
wenn ich sie nicht wirklich
und dann einfach am nächsten morgen weg
ansonsten wirklich sehen wir wirklich
direkt nach dem aufwachen und vor dem
stillen dann weißt du immer okay zweit
ich gewickelt dann bekomme ich was zu
essen und dann kann sie mitspielen oder
wieder schlafen also verlegte leben was
eigentlich jeder berater haben möchte ja
auch mehr probleme mit ella haben als
eigentlich nicht wo sie bisschen
probleme hat ist mit der haut aber da
ist es so ein bisschen empfindlich muss
ich ein bisschen gucken
ich ziehe halt dann nur baumwolle oder
wohl klamotten an und würden halt so
krems die sie ganz gut verträgt aber
ansonsten aber eigentlich keine probleme
oder doch mehr mit 1&1 hat probleme beim
handyanbieter wir haben morath habe ich
dann immer probleme geld und ein handy
ja ja ja ansonsten alles in ordnung
alles gut
genau ich stehe jetzt auch noch voll
also jetzt ist ja fünf monate alt und
ich habe mir eigentlich vorgenommen dass
ich sie mindestens sechs monate voll
stille
wobei ich das jetzt von der l abhängig
mache also irgendwann merkt man denke
ich als mama okay jetzt soll das sie
vielleicht beikost bekommen und
vielleicht ja also stinkt so im sechs
monate nachdem nach dem sechsten monat
werde ich damit anfangen und habe jetzt
auch im beikost seminar noch mal besucht
beim einer hebamme
ich finde es aber ganz wichtig dass
inhaber habt das habe ich ja schon öfter
gesagt aber ich finde es wirklich
wichtig also sie hat nicht nur so dass
ihr euch während der schwangerschaft und
der geburt und nach der geburt betreut
sondern ihr könnt ja immer eure hebamme
fragen also wirklich das ist für mich
wie solle ja es hat meine zu wie heißt
es meine meine behinderung person und da
gehe ich halt immer hin und kann sie
dann auch fragen habt auch die rück den
rückbildungskurs gemacht da schon nicht
ganz fertig aber jetzt im nächsten jahr
fertig und sie beantwortet und eben alle
fragen oder hat wenigstens nützliche
tipps und tricks und ich habe zwar schon
bei sami rat damals mit der beikost
angefangen aber man vergisst es halt
auch schnell und da war es einfach so
eine auffrischung für mich und ja
einfach nur mal ein paar infos und dann
werde ich eben damit starten wenn die
ela
so weit ist wichtig ist vor allem leute
zu fragen die wir zu tun haben also hat
er täglich
und wenn man es so im facebook forum
rhein schreibt merzig wird im internet
würde ich generell nicht nach
bbc-informationen untersuchen
vor allem wenn man zum beispiel als ich
zum beispiel bei ihrer haut gesehen habe
okay ist so leichter schüppchen gehabt
und war rot und wenn man das dann google
dann fährt man alles möglich also ich
würde es echt immer abraten
entweder direkt zum arzt sahib aber wir
wissen es eigentlich am besten also
viele meiner zuschauer haben mich schon
gefragt ob ich ob ich videos machen
könnte zur beikost das mache ich auf
jeden fall wo ich denke da fangen auch
demnächst damit an
egal ob es damit anfängt oder nicht also
ich möchte auf jeden fall noch weiterhin
stellen so lange es geht also nicht bis
fünf ist aber schon hat noch ein
bisschen säuglingsalter
und ja dann starten wir damit los da
könnt ihr mir auch gerne eure fragen
dann in die kommentare schreiben falls
ihr fragen habt ja ich wollte etwas
sagen muss ich dann probieren oder wie
macht ihr das schmeckt ja auch süße
problem ja dann haben viele gefragt wie
wir unsere kinder erziehen zweisprachig
ja das machen wir so und zwar habe ich
von anfang an mit samira auch immer ganz
viel türkisch gesprochen aber ich gab es
am ihre habe ich sogar weniger deutsch
gesprochen weil sie war ja auch das
einzige kind daheim und ich wollte
einfach dass das türkische auch so ein
bisschen mitnimmt weil ich unterhalte
mich mit murat halt mehr auf deutsch
also es ist halt echt so wer also auf
badisch und schwäbisch salome deswegen
deswegen deswegen versuchen wir halt oft
mit ihm türkisch zu reden weil wir halt
im alltag viel deutsch sprechen
meine eltern zum beispiel reden nur
türkisch mit den kindern
das wollte ich auch so einfach dass wenn
sie zu oma und opa gehen dass dann dort
not wirklich gesprochen wird und
normalerweise ist er ideal dass man halt
komplett trend also dass man sagt okay
der eine elternteil spricht türkisch der
andere nur deutsch und dass man das eben
so ein bisschen festmacht an
verschiedenen orten zum beispiel auch
ich kenne zum beispiel auch das beispiel
da gab es eine französische mutter der
dann immer nur auf dem fahrrad mit
enkelin französisch gesprochen
wir wussten die kinder hat genau wie wir
fahrrad fahren dann reden wir
französisch wenn man das so ein bisschen
trend ist es halt besser damit die
kinder das eben nicht vermischen also
ich merke mir ab und so dass es auch von
mir
wenn sie mit mir spricht aber wenn wir
dann darauf achten und ich dann sagt mir
kommen sagt mir komplett auf türkisch
dann macht sie das auch also da muss man
schon bisher darauf achten und im
kindergarten spricht sehr gut deutsch
und ja die kinder wachsen zweisprachig
auch die nur auf dem fahrrad mit dem
französisch gesprochen
das festigt sich an seinem kopf gehen
oder weiß ist okay wenn ich jetzt auf
zwar hat geht es geht dann ganz
automatisch dann spreche ich französisch
also stimme vor ich würde mit samira
gespräche mit ihrem fahrrad den das
heißt sie würden niemals gesperrt sie
scheint viel fahrrad gefahren oder im
auto oder so zum beispiel aber bei uns
geht sein und wissen so viel immer wir
reden halt oft viel deutsch und ja
versuchen deswegen dann im alltag wenn
wir privaten einfach viel türkisch zu
erreichen da waren sie beides nämlich
weise sparen extrem wichtig sie
versprachen vernachlässigen weil es erst
mal vernachlässigt und nicht oft spricht
es vergisst man ganz schnell
und dieser hat zum beispiel ganz gerne
ich habe auf youtube sondern seine
playlist gemacht für sie mit so
kindergarten liedern und da habe ich
auch so eine englische playlist
sicherlich songs heißt ist imposant
und das sind auch richtig tolle lieder
und das sind sie dann auch über fleißig
mit und auf englisch hört gern machen ja
das versteht sie dann auch das ist echt
schön und ihre freundin spricht zum
beispiel englisch und dann bringen die
sich immer gegenseitig bei oder in die
andere freundin ist kroate und dann
spricht die samira sagt sie was
türkisches die andere muss englisch ist
die andrangs kroatisch ist und irgendwie
die man immer so misch masch alten
urlaub ja im moment fängt die ella
tatsächlich auch an zu fremdeln und zwar
ist es bisher noch nie aufgefallen aber
neulich hat ein freund sie genommen und
hat sie halt nicht von sich weggedreht
sondern hat sie zu sich hin gedreht und
die die riechen das hat dann auch dass
es eben ein anderer mensch ist und ich
sehe das auch und deswegen sollte man
bei kindern wirklich immer so machen
wenn man sie auf dem schoß nimmt gerade
wenn man sie noch nie auf dem schoß
hatte und die kinder euch nicht kennen
einfach immer für euch wegdrehen dann
sehen sie nehme ich euch nicht und
riechen euch nicht und dann fremden die
netze musste stuttgart tatsache bonbons
und herstellen
ich freue mich einen tag wo ich das
erste mal dem kind so richtige nahrung
erste mal eine zitrone
das sollte sich nur so müssen erste mal
die zitrone beim baby beim kind
wahnsinnig lieb ist es ist es in mexiko
oder oder wenn ich einfach das kind nur
das erste mal was zeigen ist erstmal mal
den wald zeigen das erste mal bezahlen
konnte so wie neulich mit el arabi war
mit ihr schwimmen ja das war richtig
schön also da mit samira war ich beim
babyschwimmkurs mit ella mache ich das
nicht dagegen jetzt selber schwimmen und
man muss sie halt nur ganz langsam ans
wasser gewöhnen aber das was so schön
ich glaube jetzt öfter dass auch eine
wasserratte unser mira hat dann eben
auch ihren spaß und wir waren in so
einem thermalbad was hat auch richtig
warm sind auch nur alte menschen um uns
herum war echt witzig und da war zum
wassersport mit den älteren als mit den
senioren und die samira hatte einfach
mitgebracht genau 76 80 und wieder
mittendrin aber ja was ich dann auch
noch ansprechen wollte
also ich mache gerne zu allen themen ein
video bei manchen themen enthalte ich
mich aber auch weil ich einfach nicht
möchte dass es dann zu viele
diskussionen gibt also muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen bei im funk zum beispiel
enthalte ich mich ich glaube zum stellen
würde ich auch kein video machen weil es
einfach so viele verschiedene meinungen
gibt und ich mache sowieso das wo ich
mich persönlich am besten dabei fühle
und ich empfehle ich auch immer dasselbe
mit eurer hebamme mit ihrem arzt
auszumachen und natürlich mit eurem
partner ich denke die eltern wissen
einfach am besten was das richtige für
das kind ist
ich sehe die gefahren im internet immer
da wenn ich mir manchmal so meiner
instagram kommentare durchlese ich
wirklich alle durch nur manchmal
entdecke ich welche erst später wir sind
ja meist immer ganz positiv aber
manchmal fängt dann auch an das eben
diskussionen unter den bildern
stattfinden
warum sie in der zuschauer denn es also
nicht immer mit mir genau das hat mich
immer mit mir zu tun
aber auch unter den zuschauern da war es
zum beispiel neulich so da habe ich ein
bild von samira hochgeladen
wo man eigentlich nur die die hände von
samira sieht wie seegras füße in der
hand hat und
hat mit ihr so spielt und da hat man
eben gesehen die familie hat total kurze
fingernägel und dreckige fingernägel und
da ging eine mega diskussion dann los
und dann ich glaube irgendwann am ende
sind sie bei psychischen schäden
gelandet wirklich haben wir das bild
interpretiert also ganz ehrlich aus
solchen gründen denke ich laden viele
auch keine privaten fotos von sich hoch
weil hat immer irgendwas
hineininterpretiert wird und ja also
dass fingernägel abbauen hat sie von dem
rad durch die finger nicht auch mal dass
ich ein kind das ist ein vierjähriger
ein fünfjähriges kind natürlich da hat
meine tochter draußen mich gerade
gehegte nein
und natürlich darf meine tochter draußen
auf dem spielplatz spielen und dem sand
spielt sie darf sich dreckig machen und
schmutzig machen dann darf sie mit knete
spiel mit teig spielen und natürlich hat
sie dann halt auch mal tägliche finger
nehmen so ist ich finde es auch mal ganz
furchtbar immer in kleine kinder so was
hinein jahr mit 45 psychische schäden
oder arroganz vorwirft oder anderen
trend ist und 45 jahren kann ich noch
kein kind etwas vorwerfen solche schäden
und ich denke daher kommt es dann halt
auch dass man dann auch sagt ok dieses
kind brauche tallinn dieses kind braucht
dieses oder jenes wollen
ich weiß noch als ich mit samira da war
sie noch ganz klein und wir haben immer
so eine krabbelgruppe und das siehst du
einfach manche kinder schnell aktiver
und manches inhalt etwas weniger aktiv
also das hat er nichts damit zu tun dass
die einen hyperaktiv oder sonst was sind
da hat mir die eine mama auch erzählt
dass sie irgendwie bei der musikschule
war und dann auch der kleine ebenso
rumgerannt ist und ein anderes kind saß
aber nur herum und dann hat wirklich
eine mama tatsächlich gefragt ob sie ihr
kind nicht schon fest an ihn geben
möchte weil der hals herum rennt
unglaublich so was ist meiner schulzeit
zum beispiel erlebt da hab ich das war
irgendwie neues wahlrecht aus heftig an
das war noch vor meiner schulzeit habe
ich nachhilfe gegeben und das kind was
bei mir war die hat halt auch immer
also man hat adhs und hat auch tabletten
dagegen bekommen und an dem einen tag da
kam sie dann hast du mit sli meine mama
hat heute vergessen wir die tabletten zu
geben ich bin heute voll nervig voll
nervig und reicht erwacht und sagt doch
meine mama sagt immer immer wenn ich die
tabletten ich nehme damit ich voll
nervig und hat richtig gemerkt wie die
mutter dem kind ist eingetrichtert hat
also ganz ganz schlimmer ich will mag an
seinem kinderrad auch recht viele seien
realistische genauso wie wir mal sagt
mein kind ist kein brokkoli und das kind
sitzt neben dran
damit das kind nicht brokkoli essen also
dich damals ein psychiater in meine
kindheit ich werde chinas kindern mit
784 ausgekommen
aber welche last kinder kinder sei ja
denke dass auch gibt ihnen die
erfahrungen auch ihre grenzen kennen zu
lernen
ganz einfach dass sie mal was was was
unanständiges anstellen das ist das ganz
normal muss seine grenzen austesten und
las denn die freiheiten aber ich bin
sehr autoritär erzogen worden also wenn
mein papa reicht den grenzen sind ja
auch ganz gut aber also man hat nicht
mal sagen weil es an ihrer seite etwas
anderes bis 31 dann macht es meistens
auch mein papa war ist so einer nur
angeschaut
er muss sich aha okay jetzt mache nichts
falsches
auf jeden fall ja finde ich richtig wenn
man einfach dinge in bilder hinein
interpretiert ich meine das ist eine
momentaufnahme und keiner gibt es ein
ganzes privatleben öffentlich preis und
deswegen finde ich es immer ganz
schlecht verwahrt gerade in so
aufnahmesituationen irgendwie was hinein
interpretiert ich erzähle euch jetzt
noch kurz wie ich das an meinen drehtage
mache und zwar ist es so dass ich mich
da
nach den kindern richten also eigentlich
nicht nach samira weil samira hat zu
ihrer festen zeiten die steht morgens
meist um 7 auf und dann wird
gefrühstückt dann macht sie sich fertig
und dann kommt ja auch schon in den
kindergarten
das übernehmen dann entweder ich oder
dem hochrad je nachdem ob grad zu hause
ist es dann schon eine entlastung für
mich wenn ich dann nicht morgens noch
extra weg fahren muss dann versorge ich
noch die ella oder eben auch schon
vorher und die wir dann gestellt und
gewickelt und umgezogen und dann darfst
du erstmal in dem laufgitter spielen
beim dreh ist es dann so dass ich wie
gesagt alle 2
zwei stunden pause mache und damit
gestillt und gewickelt und bisschen
gekuschelt und dann geht es einem dreh
eigentlich auch schon weiter und sie ist
ja auch immer ziemlich ganz als ziemlich
zufrieden und liegt dann entweder da und
spielt und ich will darf er eben auch
zur wurde ich spiele oder murat spielt
mit ihr und ich gebe dir aus genau meine
mama ist dann auch ab und zu tat geht
dann auch gerne spazieren oder sie darf
mir einfach zuschauen als das macht sie
auch gerne was wenn sie war ja auch
jetzt schon öfter im video hinten drin
in ihrer wippe und liegt dann so neben
mir und da kann ich auch bisschen mit
ihr erzählen und es gibt das dann eben
mal nicht weit weg wie ja zum glück also
dass ohne meine eltern dem im ranking es
ja unter eltern auch bei amira damals
ich habe damals bei samira noch studiert
und da war auch meine mama war immer da
und hat mir immer geholfen
echt schön dass wir erst sagen also ich
glaube nicht ohne ohne ohne deine eltern
wird es nicht gehen
ja da könnte ja nicht mehr arbeiten
gehen vor allem kann ich mich dann immer
auf sie verlassen als ich das nicht
immer da wenn ich sie brauche und auch
wenn ich sie nicht braucht die sind
einfach echt immer da ist immer schön
sind beides rennt noch immer meine
eltern haben sie keine enkelkinder ist
die ersten enkel ja und ich bin zwar
eine von fünf geschwistern die
zweitjüngste aber außer mir hat noch
kein zweier geschwisterkinder
so ist ein riesen jackpot für meine zwei
aber ich bei der sanierung schlug dies
auf die welt gekommen da ist opa genau
dann in ihr ende gekommen und bei dem
rentner ist meistens so die müssen wir
erstmal selber finden mit 467 sie
plötzlich aufhören wie meine eltern
sagen halt immer ein kinder schön gut
aber die enkelkinder sind noch besser
weil ja dann sind meine eltern der mir
jetzt die zeit weil bei ihnen was er
damals genauso wie bei uns jetzt wir
arbeiten ja auch und dann hat man eben
nicht von morgens bis abends immer zeit
für die kinder und jetzt meine eltern
sind halt in rente sind zu hause und
können sich den ganzen tag wenn sie
wollen um die kinder kümmern das
schönste wäre ein haus mit montag eltern
mit drin wohnen
es wäre mein traum ja ich glaube da
haben wir so ziemlich alle fragen
beantwortet falls ihr noch fragen habt
dann stellt sie gerne in die kommentare
dann mache ich das bei meinem nächsten
baby update vielleicht kann sich ella
bis dahin schon vom bauch auf den rücken
drehen
ja ich bin schon gespannt was er anfängt
zu krabbeln usw
aber jetzt ist geradezu die zeit die du
dich gefährlich ist also wohl noch nicht
wegräumen muss und nichts baby tauglich
und babys sicher machen muss und man
kann schon viel mit ihr spielen und viel
mit ihr machen
und eigentlich jede zeit immer schön mit
unseren lachen sie morgen hülse auf stur
des lachens als allererstes schön denn
sie passt übrigens nicht mehr bei
stelberg das ist halt das ist jetzt zu
klein also ihr bei stelle bett von bbb
was ich da hatte oder er habe da hat es
sich immer so ein bisschen raus gerobbt
und lag dann irgendwann bei mir im bett
und dann haben wir gedacht komm jetzt
zeit für ein richtiges kinderbett was
ich ziemlich schade finde weil ich die
zeit mit dem bei stellt schon sehr
genossen hat weil sie und hat fast so
direkt neben mir liegt und jetzt ist
auch keines gitter zwischen uns genommen
also die seite der erste als info als
beispiele das will ich eigentlich wenn
es gebraucht kaufen
das hat jetzt noch viel kleine freundin
hat übrigens größer also wir haben das
kleine kasse aber ich hab's ja auch
abgekauft meiner freundin gebraucht
deswegen wusste ich nicht dass es auch
ein großes gibt und meine freundin hat
ein größeres da passt die kleine
wahrscheinlich noch bis zu einem halben
jahr ein ehrlichen also bei uns war
jetzt nach viereinhalb monaten markierte
film ja also nach fünf monaten schluss
ja eigentlich ja aber sich so der erste
trennungsschmerz finde ich vom beispiel
bett zum normalen bett mit guitar fällt
mir jetzt schon schwer
jetzt hat münchens zwei jahre weg lassen
also falls ihr noch fragen habt stellst
du mir gerne und falls ihr euch noch für
weitere themen interessiert wir freuen
uns natürlich über vorschläge und halten
euch auf dem laufenden
also bis zum nächsten mal ciao macht's
gut
arrivederci alle wirklich alle aßen alle
wieder